foreign ministers from the association
of Southeast Asian Nations or asean meet
to discuss ways to resolve the crisis in
Myanmar its military rulers had agreed
to a peace plan with other asean member
states in April last year to end the
unrest the countries faced since they
took power in a coup last year
but there's been no progress and the
talks in Jakarta appeared to have failed
to change that
but it is too early to mention in detail
about the recommendations
because once again the task of this
meeting is to prepare for the next
month's Summit in Phnom Peng which among
other things will have a special session
to discuss the implementation of the
five-point consensus
the consensus calls for an immediate end
to violence and dialogue between
myanmar's Junta and anti-koo opponents
but the conflict is worsening this video
shows the aftermath of airstrikes by
myanmar's military last weekend they
struck a concert in kachin state a
stronghold of the kitchen Independence
Army one of myanmar's major ethnic armed
resistance groups at least 50 people
were killed
asean is under pressure to take a
stronger stance against myanmar's
military leaders
if I were to be in the position of the
foreign ministers I would
first convey to the untha that within
three months or before the end of this
year
if there were to be no positive reaction
and pigmentation on the part of the
Kathmandu
then the first thing
would be the suspension of Myanmar the
organization has also been urged to
engage with myanmar's so-called Shadow
government opposed to the coup
for those inside Myanmar it's hard to
remain optimistic
we've been moving towards a military
solution
internally domestically
um
the options for a political solution
are running out or they never existed at
all
the Junta plans to hold an election next
year but it's being criticized by many
as a way to Grant legitimacy to military
rule
Florence Louis Al Jazeera